hello freak I'm getting
fascinated by the way your brain works
because for you it's important that the
person want to wear the suit and have a
feeling that that's sort of that's
symbolic of how you feel about life
itself like the person has to want to be
doing what they're doing they have to
want to wear that suit it has to be an
authentic gesture um did you ever read a
book called extreme ownership written by
a couple of Navy SEALs
that's Jaco willing great no no that's I
think it is is it Jacques book yeah yeah
yeah I've had jock on the show a bunch
of times important books I've read mine
once before when we're talking about a
bunch of times no I wear them once but
but a little book yes right now there's
lots of books that I picked up on this
theme but they were very eloquent about
it if you don't own something you're not
the boss you have to take full
responsibility for everything that you
do why be subservient you must be the
master of your own Kingdom philia makes
a lot of sense
you've gotta own that you can't just
walk into things with your eyes half
open you're walking to things with your
eyes fully open you've got to know what
you're getting into you have to take
possession of your life this is a
thought process you have to constantly
reaffirm there's something I did exactly
that
it's exactly that you drift on this
point right and it is whatever form of
meditation or mantra that you decide to
espouse there needs to be some period in
your day where you remember that there's
a world out there trying to tell you who
you are and as a world in here that's
trying to tell you who you are now where
do you want to put your X because the
world outside is very noisy and very
tempting and as all the razzamatazz as
all the tinsel and all the glitter it's
called the toys but that's because you
don't think you're enough in the first
place you don't think you're enough in
the first place the whole idea of the
world to sell you stuff is first of all
they have to make you feel bad about
yourself less than in some way and I
don't resent this system by the way it
is the system
but what's the expression about don't
hate don't hate the player hate the game
don't hate the game love the game
because you're in it mate mmm so own the
game accept the rules and move on into
the rules so the world will try and tell
you who you are and you have to tell
yourself who you are and there's this
ongoing battle and somehow there needs
to be a reconciliation between the two
but in the end you've got a ball the
eggs in your basket there's also an
ongoing internal battle though isn't
there there's the you that you want
people to think you are and there's a
you who you are and trying to figure out
like how do i how do I figure out who I
am
like mm do I have a correct assumption
of how the people are perceiving me and
how I actually am objectively or am i
bullshitting the world with this suit
and pocket square yeah I would say it's
exactly the scenario we're talking about
there's essentially only two two worlds
is the inner world of energy in the
outer world of energy there's there's
two identities one's real one's false
the external world is I'm asking you to
tell me who I am that's what we're all
playing it and as soon as you start play
that game we run into a source of
trouble calling the ego call it whatever
you want to call it but that's the
dynamic that we're in and somehow we
have to give ourselves enough confidence
to reassure ourselves that we are enough
however I into the game because I've got
to move on in the world without crack on
in the world and I know there's loads of
temptations that come along the way so I
will own the suit under the way the soup
I'm going to own the soup now don't mean
by paying for it I mean by owning it
it's now mine sooo it's my idea to put
on this suit I have to personalise it in
some way I have to understand a
narrative that allows me to own that
suit and thereby I've got my suit of
armor and I come out into the world and
guess what I'm in a good time because
I'm owning the suit now there's a very
rock-solid philosophy there something
you've ever written down
it's what the essence of narrative
I'm storyteller the essence of Niro
is only about this dynamic there is
nothing else in a story other than this
dynamic so the struggle between other
people's perceptions in your own wants
and desires and who truly are your your
significant real self that's it that's
all there is you tell me a story that
didn't that we engaged in that famous
that's not about this journey I could be
an example the prodigal son parable
Christian seems religious didn't really
make my sense so you know the story sure
but one should lay it out so there's a
father he has two sons an old son a
younger son and he says to them who
wants to spend their inheritance the
younger side says me Dada can't spend it
and the younger son takes all the dough
and he runs off and sniffs coke off
strippers tits for a number of years
until he realizes this is getting pretty
boring and I'm in a lot of trouble he
ends up feeding throwing food to pigs
that's his job and he can't even eat the
food that he gives to the pigs at which
point he says dad will you take me back
dad then goes - they don't meet this
somehow
happens not through telephones it just
happens
at which point dad goes to the fatted
calves has killed the fatted calf older
sons hold on dad what's going on
I've stayed with you since the beginning
I've been loyal to you and I hear the
stories of my younger brother coming
back who's been sniffing coke off
strippers tits for the last habit from
those how many years and you'll prepare
to kill the fatted calf what's the SP
dad I want another story this is your
right son don't worry about that you
take a look slide a little step to the
side you'll always be with me you're a
good boy at which point it goes out to
me the prodigal son the wasteful son the
wasteful son returns
and he says you were lost and they have
found that's the end of the story it's
quite hard to make sense of that in a
literal sense you get old and was a bit
unfair me you should have been kind to
the oldest son because he never ran off
and did anything
but the essence of the story is that you
are the father you are enough your older
son is your intellect says all Daniel is
been doing that is trying to reconcile
make sense of a prosaic and material
world
the younger son being the wild feral
entity that he is once go out the world
and find out what it's all about so in
his recklessness and sense of adventure
he finds that you can't escape himself
so he has to return to himself and at
which point he has to accept who he is
which born intellect is left out the
equation pretty much is the older
brother because he can't understand the
significance of the journey of the
wasteful brother in the end you have to
leave yourself to understand the value
of yourself you have to lose stuff
before you realize that all the stuff
that you're losing is ephemeral and
transitory it's not yours you're enough
you're always enough but you've got to
somehow prostitute yourself before you
realize your own value that is the
essence of all stories dad's deep
Garrety so tell me you think about all
the time was this I mean there's like a
cemented philosophy lip so King Arthur
story you just made a man is a king has
a son a son the father is runs into a
bit of a Grove the son jumps into a
little boat a little skillet and he's
not skillet that's what you cook your
chops on internet yeah I'm skiff little
skiff the skiff takes off down the river
he gets found by prostitutes he's
brought up in a brothel he understands
the ways of the street he becomes a king
on the street he works his way up at
different ladders and then he pulls a
sword from a stone at a certain point
his life a certain point of evolution
and then from there he goes on to be the
king a little bit tassel or along the
way lots of wrestling matches and the nd
Feist and his demons it becomes the king
so what's the significance of this
narrative that
every man in himself is eros necrotic
there he is his own king he takes us
adjourn into the material world has to
climb up all the different runs on the
ladder and ultimately has to return to
himself the significance of the
extraction from the sword from the stone
is the stone is the material world the
material world which seems will solid
because it controls you whilst you're
projecting your sense of identity upon
it the extraction of the stone is taking
back your own Authority your own
divinity your own authority your own
identity whatever it is that you've got
to call it your own power you're no
longer looking for a sense of self
outside of yourself and then you have to
face the demons that you've created in
your history by facing them and fighting
them and owning them you put them in the
face of who you are and that's a
wrestling match you'd have to take away
all these crutches and that's all that
we struggle from in life is taking away
our crutches oh please tell me I am all
please give me a bit more money so other
people think I'm clever or when then I
have a nice cut on people think I'm
clever you've got to take away all these
crutches and spand as the man that you
are and you're liberated from your whole
thing that is the story King Arthur
there's not just the story yeah it's the
story of all narrative do you think that
most people that are watching the film
are going to get that though they're
just going to get an entertaining story
they're just going to see a bunch of
cool stuff some drama play out but this
is fascinating that you're operating so
many levels underneath it if I'm
storytellers my business so I'm in the
business a store I might as well
understand story and do you need to
understand all that I'm not sure if you
do depends where you are on the ladder
so you can just go along have a nice bit
of entertainment good guy bad guy
everything is literal there's nothing
wrong with literalism it is what it is
it's the game you can glean what you can
glean when you're ready to glean what
you're ready to glean are you Joseph
Campbell fan I am a jose california yeah
that mean that's a reoccurring theme in
his work the hero's journey as the
hero's journey this underlying sort of
narrative that just really guides all
all stories and all ancient tales and
that there's something inherently human
about them important about these stories
they resonate with our wants and needs
and goals and even also maybe the
structure
that we really truly need in our own
life yeah I mean all the stories from
whatever period I'm sympathetic to this
particular to Joseph Campbell's
philosophy on this but he's not the only
one right right the weird thing about
religion is religion has done to this
spiritual significance of narrative what
the businessman did to the suit
he's literal eyes dit didn't realize
that putting on a suit is putting on a
suit of armor he's putting on something
that's rather spectacular it's just
doing it for convention you're doing for
others you're not doing it for you and
in our literal mind we look at a
narrative and we see the narrative for
what we believe it to be the exterior
aspect of narrative so we completely we
see the world upside down we don't we're
not actually interested in the essence
of the narrative because we're so busy
pandering after the approval of others
so everything that we see every
narrative that we listen to every film
that you see you're not really
interested in its soul you're interested
in its body because that's what we
correspond to it's fascinating that
you're comparing it to suits because it
resonates like when you think of a guy
showing up for work or getting ready for
work he doesn't want to go and he's
putting on a suit and it's just dredging
through it and putting it on and all you
think about a guy who is crisply tucking
in his collars and putting on his
cufflinks and tightening up his tie and
it feels empowered by the whole process
of it it's very it's very appealing like
if you see it in a film - it's very
exciting this is a man of purpose they
did it in mean streets so though you
remember Harvey Keitel getting dressed
to go up on a Friday getting dressed to
go out the Friday night and affected a
whole generation of people about the way
they dress because he owned it yeah yeah
I never really thought about that until
this conversation so because I just I
don't really wear suits occasionally
look very very careful that you've been
robbed I've been robbed you've been
robbed there are so many aspects of life
food for a long time ago robbed from us
and we've slowly managed to claw
that bags true um but clothes
really you're a 45 year old geezer and
you're still dressing like an 18 year
old house is a lot about well some
people like to be comfortable though I
get that by the way and they like that
look comfortable your subscriptuin
comfortable yeah you can get poured into
this completely deconstructed on the
inside maybe by that chap called
Brunello knows what he's doing so these
are all handmade it's sort of won't be
handmade tailored no you bought this off
the shelf and I had only a couple of
things tweaked but it's as comfortable
as a pair of pajamas really yeah see
again you have to broker a deal you
can't put on things are uncomfortable
because guess what happens in the
morning you're looking through you soon
as you go on like that one but unaware
and what a comfortable one ah so they
all have to be comfortable
well you know play the game I
[Applause]
[Music]